what's going on everybody welcome to the
beginning of my series dedicated to
bitcoin trading
so if you didn't already know uh
bitcoin's a non-centralized and
non-regulated cryptocurrency and
generally you can hear people say it's
like decentralized or deregulated
but it was either it was never either of
those so the whole d thing doesn't quite
make sense
um so the money is just controlled by a
peer-to-peer network secured by this
encryption so it makes it pretty much
impossible to crack
and even if you couldn't if you could
crack it it would just make more sense
to dedicate that computing power towards
being a part of the system rather than
cheating it
so
that's pretty much all i'm going to
really mention on that if uh if you want
to know more about the intricacies of
like what exactly bitcoin is uh and how
it kind of works fundamentally then i
definitely suggest you check out there's
a tutorial video put up by khan academy
and they cover it very well as far as
like the fundamentals of how bitcoin
actually works and all that
uh also if you're looking for bitcoin
mining you're not going to really find
that here in my opinion bitcoin mining
is just like a massive rat race and in
the long term pretty much everybody has
to lose that race or at least most
people have to lose that race
it's a great model for efficiency but
it's going to require you to make you
know constant leaps forward even just to
keep up and so if you're
for example a lot of people buy bitcoin
mining stuff
uh like you know gear that's
specifically made to mine bitcoin um
doesn't really make any sense because if
if you're going to be
if it's going to be lucrative for you
you're going to have to be ahead of the
crowd but if you're buying something
you're just you're like
making yourself part of the crowd so um
don't really see the point in that so
now you know what bitcoin represents is
you know a plausible seismic shift in
the entire way the world works power
allocation and all of that right i mean
from the ground up bitcoin is all about
just freedom right and the system itself
is nothing short of beautifully
brilliant right
when it comes to comparing bitcoin to
really any other currency that we have
today you know all these currencies are
fiat currencies anyways you're gonna be
hard-pressed to logically prove um with
reasoning why bitcoin is inferior to any
other currency yet there you you can
find a lot of reasons why you might
consider it uh superior
uh to those other currencies so
so with that let's let's go go ahead and
get on to what i intend to really cover
in this series and that's going to be a
hard look in trading
bitcoin okay
so as always
when it comes to this kind of stuff my
videos covering this sort of activity
are purely educational only
i'm not here to suggest to you guys that
you buy into bitcoin or sell bitcoin or
do any sort of financial transaction at
all uh you're all big people you're
responsible for your actions and uh
so yeah so for the legal reasons i also
probably ought to add if you're not a
big person as in you're not considered
an adult in your country then for legal
reasons i must say that you are not
permitted by me to watch this video
so with that along those lines the
interesting thing about bitcoin um and
source for you know future controversy
no doubt is that it's you know there are
no government control
you know regulation laws whatever
anything that dictates bitcoin and who
can take part in this system right it's
just free for all um so like recently
china did just ban their banks from
dealing with bitcoin but
um actually banning anybody from using
it is
near implied i guess banning people from
using it isn't impossible but
um actually stopping people from using
it uh it's like the war on drugs right
and it's a it's a good analogy to use
because
um like people say bitcoin is anonymous
but you could still be made illegal and
just because it's anonymous doesn't mean
it can't be made illegal and you can't
get in trouble for it
there's like no you know ledger out
there that says who you uh sold your pot
to or what not but you still can get in
trouble so
um so yes it is it can be anonymous if
you take the proper steps but again
there is actually a huge ledger um for
all your bitcoin transactions that's
completely public which is great uh and
if you want to stay anonymous there's a
lot of things you still need to kind of
do about it uh about that but anyway
back to what i was talking about um
like a lot of well at least along the
lines of that you know like you're
protected by the 256 aes encryption but
a lot of exchanges are going to require
that you provide a personal id right and
all this kind of stuff so um
yeah but you obviously don't have to use
an exchange at all to buy and sell
bitcoin you can do this peer-to-peer
purely um it's just it's nice when you
use an exchange um
so anyway
children can indeed get into trading
bitcoin unlike trading stocks or forex
where you must be an adult you know
simply just because of the laws of the
land right
now this kind of hits close to home for
me because i actually made a living as a
kid and then even through uh university
uh in the engaging of exchanging of uh
virtual currency for real-life us
dollars that wasn't in bitcoin but it
was in another virtual currency and so
you know i don't know how i totally feel
about it uh you know playing in the
market is a bit of gambling and so it's
def i understand the laws why uh
why um
countries and so our governments want to
protect their children from losing all
of their
value in in something like this but
anyway
uh this non you know regulation makes
margins pretty nice anybody can take
part profitability is is fairly easy but
so is loss
um
so you know like with bitcoin pretty
much anybody can trade on their own
anybody can open up their own exchange
charge any fees and whatever so this
obviously brings a lot of competition uh
but it also brings high risk since it
isn't regulated it takes nothing really
i mean you do you have to jump through
some hoops just as you know get on board
with various financial institutions to
be able to do stuff like this but for
the most part um there's no
uh you know license exams or anything
like this or background checks for you
and all this kind of stuff
officially
um
so this means as well uh that
bitcoin it has no
value at the moment um in the eyes of
the law really
it's not regulated so if someone steals
all of your bitcoin there's
a sort of street justice there's nothing
you can do and chances are street
justice is illegal in your country
so you're just screwed
and this sort of thing has happened and
i've not heard of any retribution to the
folks who have ran off with people's
money um so yeah so keep in mind that
just because you you know you found a
website that promises
x or tells you that you can gain one
percent interest a day just by storing
your bitcoins with them
it doesn't mean that your precious coins
are going to be there tomorrow morning
when you wake up or the website for that
matter right so in every sense you know
it's the wild west uh the only reason
people have to not steal your money is
either you know they have morals which
is quite rare these days um or
um their reputation is worth more than
that or the profit they're making from
their business so an exchange like uh
mount gox for example who's you know the
number one exchange
charges
point six percent uh mostly because of
their reputation where an exchange like
btc dash e is going to charge uh 0.2
percent um but as you'll find out later
on we'll we'll probably in the next
video discuss
what exchange you ought to consider and
why and all this
um
it might not might still be best not to
go with mount gox anyway so if all you
do is is watch this video and think
you're going to go to mount gox and
trade listen to what i have to say in
the next video
um
so you know but the idea of it is you
know like well mount gox currently is
attempting to
to
um you know hold their reputation as
well and lately they've been having some
trouble and so has bitcoin especially
with the most more uh recent uh banning
in china
and even someone like mount gox right
let's consider mount cox and where mount
gox came from um if nobody knows uh let
us
visit
web.archive
there we go
let me bring this uh window down here
now mount gox uh let's see how mount gox
got its start
mountgox.com
so mount gox actually originated as a
website all about trading cards for
magic the gathering it literally stands
for mtg ox as magic the gathering um
online exchange so so here's an old
thing back in uh when was this 2007.
uh this was mount gox um
and then they tried to be like some sort
of video game or something i think in
2011.
that didn't work out and then finally
they actually did get purchased
um i forget who who actually forget the
guy's name but i don't think it's the
same dude that's actually running it now
that um so the domain name was purchased
by somebody apparently anyway so this is
you know very early on here's bitcoin at
uh three dollars wow and very nice uh
graph they have going on here
anyway um
so that's mountain gox and again this is
uh 2011. i'm filming this on december
7th 2013 so these people have been
around for two and a half years
um
at least so we've so we see so let's
look here real quick and see where
they're doing on this date
um back in 09 pretty sure this is where
they were doing their little uh
video game stuff
yeah um
you're a warlord in the outskirts of the
known world struggling blah blah okay so
you get the point uh this website's
pretty young and considering the amount
of effort required to build this website
and the amount of time and the amount of
money that they could make if they just
ran off right now
um it's pretty scary so
so even though mount gox is in theory
number one but quite possibly losing it
stay tuned for the next video um
you still have to keep in mind that the
crazy amount of risk involved in this
system right
um so anyways uh that's my that's my
introduction here if you guys were
paying any attention i've got the the
prices of bitcoin in the background here
and just a few ideas right off as far as
you know how you can trade this is uh
right now this orange line is mount gox
uh the white line or white-ish line is
the btc-e
and both of these are the the bitcoin to
usd ratio and as you can see the gap is
actually quite large uh for the most
part uh and then it did come come in a
little bit there um so this graph is
about the last hour of prices
um
so but normally you're going to see this
massive gap it's actually very rare that
the gap is this
uh small for this long
probably um
either
um
uh bitcoin or btc-e is gonna just
plummet down even further or we'll see
mount gox shoot up uh to a pretty
significant degree usually the gap is
you know about
25
or so but as we can see here i mean
they're very close about within four
dollars and so a lot of people do ask
about arbitrage and all this stuff and
so yeah we will be actually uh talking
all about
um
quite a bit of different trading methods
that you might want to consider and all
that but first it's good to introduce
everybody the the main issue is
uh there's plenty of information about
what bitcoin is there's a lot of
information about mining bitcoin uh the
information however to actually trade
bitcoin is very very sparse
um and it's littered with uh scams and
viruses
so
there's always that so anyway
hopefully i'll be able to help you guys
out at least educate you on what's
what's out here what what this is all
about and either convince you that you
might want to do it or even convince you
or talk you out of uh dealing with it at
all
so anyway as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and the
subscriptions and until next time